YURI GRINSHTEYN: We've seen how
to collect observability data
from services running
in Google Cloud.
But what if you
still have services
on prem or in other clouds?
Today, I'm going to show
you how to determine
the right observability strategy
for a hybrid or multi-cloud
environment.
This is the "Stack Doctor."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Before we start, let's
talk about what hybrid
and multi-cloud really means.
People often think that
hybrid and multi-cloud
means having a
single workload that
runs across multiple
infrastructure providers.
But in practice, this
rarely works as advertised.
The added latency and
cost of network egress
makes this largely impractical.
We see much more success
with a hybrid model
where different providers are
used for different workloads
and, often, by different teams.
However, this introduces
observability challenges.
How can you standardize
things like SLOs,
observability, and alerting
across all these platforms?
Generally speaking,
you have two options.
The first is to use Google Cloud
as the single pane of glass
and send your observability
data from other platforms there.
There are well-documented
integration options for this,
and I'll get into those shortly.
Your second option is to
use a third-party service
as your single pane
of glass and have
it consume observability
data that's either
collected by cloud
monitoring and logging
or emitted directly by your
Google Cloud resources.
Let's review a few examples
for the first option--
using Google Cloud as
your single pane of glass.
You may need to ingest
observability data
from multiple platforms,
monitor Kubernetes clusters,
or collect logging data
from multiple sources.
You can use BindPlane, a
solution from Blue Medora,
a Google Cloud Partner, to
import monitoring and logging
data from both on-prem VMs
and other cloud providers.
This architecture has
one main advantage.
There are no additional
licensing costs
for using BindPlane.
BindPlane metrics are
imported into cloud monitoring
as custom metrics, which are
charged at standard rates.
Likewise, BindPlane
logs are charged
at the same rate as other logs.
If you're looking
to monitor workloads
on Kubernetes clusters
running both in Google
Cloud and elsewhere, you can use
the combination of Prometheus,
cloud monitoring, and the cloud
monitoring Prometheus sidecar
to ingest Prometheus
metrics into monitoring
for a unified
monitoring approach.
Finally, you can use
a similar approach
to collect logs from
multiple Kubernetes clusters
by using Fluentd, a popular
open-source logging agent,
and having it send both
infrastructure and application
logs to Cloud Logging.
We've now covered
using Google Cloud
as your single pane of glass.
Let's look at our
other pattern--
exporting data from Google Cloud
to our third-party service.
In this scenario, there
are two primary methods
of sending that information.
The first method involves
the third-party tool
integrating with a monitoring
API to consume metric data.
For logs, you'll have to
set up a Cloud Logging
export to a Pub/Sub topic.
You'll then be able to
connect your preferred
tool as a subscriber
to receive those logs.
For the other method,
you may choose
to leave the data
where it is and simply
aggregate at the
presentation layer.
Grafana is an excellent
way to achieve this
and can be used with
multiple backends,
including Cloud Monitoring.
I hope this walkthrough of
common architecture patterns
to build out a hybrid
or multi-cloud approach
to observability with
Google Cloud helps you
as you plan your journey.
That's it for this episode.
Come back soon for more.
This is the "Stack Doctor."
Stay healthy out there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]